seillant numéro 1 de franz schubert un
trio pour piano violon et violoncelle et
créée en 1827 par le compositeur
autrichien schubert a un vécu à peine 30
ans donc effectivement il a été composé
un an avant sa mort donc ce sont des
oeuvres de maturité on dit aussi qu'il
est libéré parce que beethoven pierre
juste de mourir donc il est libéré de
l'emprise de béton c'est vrai dans ces
dernières années il s'exprime pleinement
il sait qu'il est condamné parce qu'il
est malade et donc il sait qu'il est
condamné
donc il ya tous acquis qui transparaît
schubert un pilier du mouvement
romantique de la musique de chambre que
ces trois solistes de lavilledieu ne se
lassent de reprendre et de proposer au
public saint quentinois
ça fait longtemps que je les joue je les
connais je les travaille et retravaille
et puis voilà ça mûrit un petit peu avec
vous et après ça on évolue avec c'est le
propre des chefs-d'oeuvre c'est qu'on
évolue avec eux et ils vis avec vous et
cdc des oeuvres qu'ils sont c'est comme
quand vous lisez vous un grand roman
quand vous lisez 20 ans vous voyez pas
les mêmes choses ou disais pas même
chose quand vous le lisez à canton près
de deux siècles plus tard les trios de
schubert invite toujours au voyage dans
l'esprit du compositeur l'amour et la
nature
[Musique]